archicad is one of the best softwares i
personally believe that anybody can use
in our profession as architects or
designers if you haven't used archicad
before and this is the first time you're
jumping onto archicad 25 this is the
video for you
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas and welcome back to the channel
if you're new here firstly thank you so
much for joining me on this channel we
talk all things technology and
architecture
that usually revolves around archicad
arcade 25 technology reviews apps and
everything in between if that's
something that interests you smash the
subscribe button down below
today we're going to be talking about
archicad 25 and as if it was your very
first time
ever jumping onto archicad so if you're
a regular subscriber to this channel
looking for a good arc cad tutorial this
isn't it for you today this is all about
the first time subscribers the guys
looking to dive into arcade as far as
they can go but have absolutely no idea
where to start if that's you this is the
perfect video for you there's also a
bunch of links down below if you want to
check them out there's a discord chat
with an ever-growing community there's
some digital downloads to help guide you
through your sketch design and
construction drawing checklists and even
a patreon link if you want access to all
of my archicad files that i do for
youtube and create on these tutorials
anyway enough of my rambling let's turn
around to these two screens and get
started all right so this is the first
time you've opened up arcade 25 you've
gotten to this main screen where it asks
you for a brand new project you can
start with any of the templates
available to you you can browse download
templates from other people you can
check out a whole bunch of different
things but in my personal opinion you're
more than likely going to start with the
australian select template if you're in
australia or any of your available
templates work environment you can go
through any of these but we're going to
adjust it to make sure it suits at least
how i work the best and how i think it
is the most practical obviously you can
change your work environment as much as
you need but we'll get into that so
let's start by pressing create the new
project and dive straight in to what
arcade 25 is so once arcade 25 is open
you will see this main screen and it is
what we basically look at all day every
day on the left hand side here we have
our main palette it basically
encapsulates everything that we're going
to use from a design and documentation
point of view everything from our walls
to our warlands our doors windows window
corners you can go through them one by
one to see exactly what they are we'll
go through them in a little bit more
detail individually soon and down below
you're going to have more of your
documentation tools so things like grid
lines
dimensioning tools text fill basically
anything that's 2d is going to be here
and anything that is
more than likely 3d is going to be here
i say in that way because lamp tools
aren't always 3d
some objects can be 2d but that's just
getting into the nitty-gritty of it on
the right hand side over here at the
moment we have a relatively good setup
going on if you don't see what i see
over here on the right hand side simply
come across to the top go window go
palettes and ensure that your palette
list looks exactly the same as mine i
don't have too many things open it is
predominantly the toolbox info status
bar the navigator which is this main
section over here the trace and
reference which is this top layer and
last but not least i always turn on the
renovation layer so that installs this
element down the bottom what you're
going to see on this right hand panel is
our trace and reference layer if you're
looking at the ground floor and want to
see what's on the footings you can
activate the trace and reference layer
to see what we've drawn on the floor
below floor above or any selected floor
you can activate it change the color of
the trace reference you can change the
opacity as well and you can also change
the active color so it can contrast
better if you're struggling to see
through the transparency layers you have
these different options of hiding and
showing different layers they each do
individual things depending on what
you're trying to achieve you might be
able to click through these and find the
best view for you in each individual
circumstance moving down this sidebar we
have our main navigator this is how we
work our way through archicad 25 and
through the projects in general
as you can see the australian select
template has sketch design design
development construction exchange and
coordination and a bunch of other files
created by default if we open up sketch
design for example it's going to give us
our survey plan our location plan our
site plan and everything in our sketch
plans sections and elevations so the
easiest way to understand this section
here is plans actually defined in our
navigator whilst sections and elevations
are created on our workspace if we wish
to create a secondary
floor plan we can come into our project
user here go show organizer which will
open up our main organizational palette
so the project map is the main house in
3d and the project the view map is the
2d floor plan the view map is basically
where we customize everything to suit
our needs so if we don't like this
layout they've created we can go ahead
and actually create our own custom
folders that house different plans
and all sorts of different elements the
best way i can give you an example is if
for instance you have an alteration
addition project where you need to draw
demolition plans existing plans and
proposed plans that isn't exactly
showcased here but you have the ability
to create those files if you wanted to
create another layer another level we
would simply press command 7 or control
7 depending on what system you are and
adjust the story settings
so as a very basic example if we go
insert below type footings
and just for the purposes of argument go
minus 172.
this is in millimeters in australia
clicking ok
you'll see that story automatically pops
up here
so if you're doing a very large project
like an apartment complex or a huge
multi-story residential building that
could be a commercial mixed use hospital
whatever it might be you can go ahead
and press ctrl 7 command 7
open up these story settings and simply
break it down into as many or as little
floor plans as you need if for example
we wanted to drag this footings layer
across to somewhere in this project map
and it didn't automatically show up like
it has been programmed here we simply
just click drag let go and slot it
wherever we want i don't want that there
so i'll just quickly delete it and close
this organizer page down below we're
going to find that renovation filter
layer that i activated in the window
settings which basically just allows us
to dictate if an object is existing to
be demolished or if it's new this is
very useful in an alteration edition
project any old buildings that need a
little bit of love a little bit of
attention you can draw that existing
building as existing smack it as
demolition and then start drawing a new
one and you can quickly flick through
those individual layers those individual
files basically without having to
duplicate the file so you can quickly
jump back to your existing plan or just
see your demolition plan or just see
your brand new plan you don't actually
have to go back and model and change in
all sorts of different arcade files like
we used to that's just a very simple
feature that's been around for a while
underneath that is our renovation
filters and that's just simply how you
dictate what's shown on your screen if
we go to our renovation filter options
we have basically a plethora of
different options and
different styles that we can choose from
adjust change as we see fit
we can graphically override every single
individual element but that's really
going into the details of arcade and
probably something you don't need to
worry about on day one but it's good to
know that this feature is available to
you if for some example you wish your
demolition line to be blue instead of
red for any particular reason if we go
and cancel out of all that and go back
to our main toolbars at the top you'll
see we have our typical toolbars at the
top file hosts everything it usually
does and you can work your way through
these
to see everything that is available to
you to be honest there isn't too many
critical things you need to know about
but i will only go through the most
important things in this toolbar that
you'll probably use in day one or at
least week one first of all open close
save save as all very basic you know how
they work you don't have to have them
explained libraries and objects and
library manager this one is probably one
of the most critical if you're importing
any external libraries if your company
has libraries that they're importing
into the project if you're starting work
for a brand new company and have never
used archived before this is definitely
something you're going to need to know
it's very critical all you have to do is
go add find that folder with the
libraries import it and arcad will do
the rest now coming back out of that and
going to our info section under file and
project info
the project info basically dictates
everything about the project in a very
simple and organized manner if we type
in the project name the description the
project id or any of these details down
here we can simply replicate them later
on by producing auto text
that is very very useful to anybody
doing a title block it means they don't
have to go through every single page and
change the client's name the client
details the page numbers etc they can do
everything in this one project info
space and it's all done and dusted again
if you're starting out a new firm using
archicad this is something you're
probably going to have to know because
this is exactly how you're going to
change all of those company details for
that project and import all that new
information continuing to move across in
the edit menu very simple very basic
stuff that i won't go too deep into the
only thing really is find and select
which the shortcut is command f this is
a very very useful tool in arcade if
you're looking for a wall you can simply
click on a wall click this copy settings
button and click the plus and it will
find everything you can go through add
multiple filters to this
and really
nail down your criteria to see exactly
what you're looking for
it's something that i use more and more
of every single day and the more you
start using this
the better you'll thank yourself in the
future because you'll be clicking less
and less and just letting the computer
do the work for you vue is a critical
one that has a few different elements
that are really important because it
basically dictates what you see on the
screen and how you see it on the screen
if we go to our view options you'll see
these are the basic settings that are
set up for me this is the archicad
australia 25 template so this is just
what's basically always there for most
people in australia now a lot of people
have wall intersection problems you
might not want to see where your roof
pivots you might need to see your stair
base lines these are basically just
things how they're displayed on your
screen not how they print out the one
thing i do turn off is true line weight
true line weight basically shows you
exactly how thick that line is going to
print out compared to everything else
i personally turn it off only because
the template has been set up that i know
each line weight quite well and i don't
need to know the line weights as thick
bars instead i can actually focus on the
individual elements and the details so
that's something i turn off you can turn
this construction grid and editing plane
display off if we jump to our 3d you'll
see i don't have them on but if i come
back to view and turn my editing plane
off for example
it shows up smack bang in 3d i don't
really use it i don't really like it i
turn it off it's completely up to you
guys what you do with those settings
moving further down in the view menu
there's probably not too much except
your 3d view options down here if you
want to look at your 3ds in a
perspective or an axonometric view
that isn't critical again today one it's
something that you will experiment and
use a lot more later down the track i
just completed an axonometric video in
my last tutorial so if you want to
really dive deep into
what is a relatively simple tutorial for
beginners that might be a good stepping
stone after this video
but these two provide some good
perspectives on how your 3ds can look
and what you can actually achieve with
them
moving into design day one again you're
probably not going to have to go through
every single bit into this menu the only
thing i recommend you look into is story
settings like we went to before which is
control or command 7 and also the
connect and the solid element operations
connect is going to allow you to trim
walls to roofs and those sorts of things
and solid element operations is going to
allow you to do that with much more
control the same goes for the rest of
these titles at the top there isn't
really too much you need to worry about
or focus on it's just really diving too
far into archicad for day one it's not
something you need to know you will
eventually find out what they do what
they are for
but day one
definitely not worth diving that far
into it you're just going to be
overwhelmed and think this isn't worth
jumping from whatever program i'm on
right now next we're going to have our
main palette toolbars here which we can
adjust and change in our window menu so
if we go toolbars you'll see these are
the basic elements that i have ticked on
there isn't anything really else i need
per se to be turned on over here you can
click on one of these for example let's
go documentation tools and it will give
you everything that we have down here if
we close that box come back up to window
toolbars let's turn drafting aids on and
we'll see a different palette
pop up in the middle of the screen if we
don't want it to be just floating like
that we can use our cursor and basically
drag and drop it into where we want it
to go if we want to move it around
change it we can do that as well but for
the time being we're just going to leave
it as is so moving across we have a
whole bunch of different elements each
one tells you what they are so if you
hover your mouse over it you're going to
be able to see what everything does so
for example if we continue moving across
the parallel constraints are quite good
it allows you to do some flexibility
with your 2d lines not really required
not too
important at the start of the day the
save tool is always important backwards
and forwards again this toolbar probably
won't be too highly used on your first
day you're mainly going to be focusing
on this palette over here so basically
that is the overall ui of archicad 25
and archicad in general we do have this
small toolbar down the bottom which is
more focused on scale and display of
materials display of line types and
orientation of the actual project it
isn't something again i would dive too
far into day one
but because it's predominantly set up
correctly so it will focus more on the
rest of arcade 25 more so than the
general ui of useless or more advanced
features that are way beyond day one
users okay so basically you've now
understood the general parameters of
where things are in archive25 what they
do how they're really used and what is
the purpose of them but how do you
actually go ahead and start drawing
something on archicad well we go back to
our 3d objects over here and our 3d
palette
it is the most critical one to use
because arcad is a 3d modelling software
we want to be able to actually
incorporate everything in 3d or as much
as we can that's why from a
philosophical point of view at least
this sits higher up than this 3d more
important than 2d very simple way to
remember that this is a 3d modeling
program so it's basically as simple as
clicking dragging and dropping if we
click on our wall tool we'll see our
toolbar automatically changes if we
click on our door again it changes to
that relevant item that we are using so
i'll click on roof once again changes
once more so let's start as our wall
tool the most basic of all
we have our settings dialog box if we
click it and open that up we have all of
our settings for our wall it dictates
the height of that wall the construction
of that wall what kind of material
composites make it up what the wall
actually is
by default arcade has plenty to choose
from more than enough you probably won't
need to create your own composite day
one how our wall interacts with other
walls how it stands does it lean where
does it start at project zero what it
will look like and how it will perform
on our floor plan and in section and
then any material overrides as well we
do have a structural analysis and a
classifications and properties manager
as well however again not for day one
users just over complicating it we don't
really need to worry about anything
there so we'll just click escape
this is our layers tool basically the
layers tool is a very simple
organization method it allows you to put
things on relevant layers the same way
you do in photoshop or illustrator if
you've used either of those two programs
it lets you adjust things for different
views so if for an example on the site
plan you want to see all the services
and all the site relative information
you turn those layers on but then you
can turn them off on the ground floor or
the first floor where you're trying to
focus on something completely different
we can change all of those settings by
simply clicking control or command and l
for larry and you'll see we have our
default model view layout settings over
here so if we were to click on our site
plans this would be activated if we were
to click on our floor plans
that would be activated and individually
we can adjust and change them
if for example i untick something we can
update that model view so it
automatically updates it for everything
the alternative method to that is
pressing control l again turning off the
one thing we don't want to see just
specifically in that view pressing ok
coming down to that individual views
settings so let's say we're on the
ground floor plan
and i've turned off those walls external
if i click settings
and go get current window settings it's
going to save those settings just
specifically for that view that i'm in
right now not for all the views
associated with that template so
continuing on i got a little bit
sidetracked there with the layer system
the wall tool has a number of different
options at the top if you want it to be
in a polygonal line if you wanted to be
a single line how you basically want to
draw that wall if you want to draw it as
a circle or if you want to draw it as a
trapezoidal object and it's basically
just giving you a bit of freedom to
adjust your wall shapes moving further
across we have where the inside or the
outside face goes
now personally i have it on the outside
face set as the outside face for a very
simple reason and i know that people
have commented saying that they use the
inside face on that is their main point
of reference and it's always the inside
but that is a completely different way
of drawing everybody has their own
standards around the world so
take what i say with a pinch of salt and
draw it however you want
but the reason i have it as outside face
drawing with the outside face is because
once it's submitted to council the
council has approved it it can no longer
move outside its parameters in a
residential property without affecting
another council requirement so if for
example a wall structure changes and it
goes from a 90 mm timber frame to a 120
mil timber frame by the choice of either
myself the client or anything else it
pushes the whole house inwards and yes
you lose internal space but the actual
physical house doesn't move so that's
why i always keep it as outside face
personally this is basically more of the
same settings that we saw in our command
t or our first
dialog settings box over here and it
continues all the way across it is a
very simple way to really just
go through it quicker and you can scroll
through those now if we were to click on
that wall tool again learnt everything
at the top about that toolbar we can
then simply click once you'll see our
wall started to become drawn if we think
that external line for example now is on
the bottom side and say that is this
section here is our internal of our
house it's the wrong way around we can
tap the p button
and now it's on the correct outside of
the house if we simply hold shift it'll
make sure it stays in a dead straight
line so clicking once twice three times
four times we've drawn a
very very simple box
but if we come into 3d we can see
exactly what we've drawn from the get-go
in 3d orbiting moving around very simple
if you click the scroll wheel you can
pan if you hold shift and the scroll
wheel you orbit
if you want to click our little man down
the bottom and explore
we can basically play it like a video
game move your mouse around to move the
camera w
s d
a moves it around c and space moves it
up and down and you basically just move
around if you want to go a little bit
faster hold the shift key and it will
move faster if you want to go extremely
faster you can tap the greater than or
less than symbol to see down the bottom
here i can't move my mouse at the same
time but just there where the speed
button is if i go greater than my speed
significantly increases less than symbol
my speed decreases so that's the general
parameters of how you move around in 3d
in archicad 25 and most likely all other
arc cads for a very long time
at least up until archicad 18 or
something as far back as i can remember
personally but i can't really vouch for
any further than that i do think it's
very similar moving through all the
arcades finally if we jump back into our
ground floor plan we have the luxury and
liberty of simply clicking on our door
if we go to our doors we can change all
of our settings clicking through them to
adjust them to check them to see them
feel free to go through some of my other
tutorials that are archicad 25 24 in 30
minutes or 45 minutes to get a better
understanding of what we need to change
here and adjust to make it work
but we can close out of that
and simply if i was to tap escape again
go door tool line it up where i want it
click once where does the door want to
go
click twice
go back to 3d here's my door
it's that simple and it's that easy it's
exactly the same principle with the
windows again the toolbar will have more
options click once click again
and there's our window completely
finished dropped into the wall all done
and dusted and last but not least is our
object tool so if we click on our object
tool and then go to our settings we can
search for a number of different objects
already available in archicad the most
common are obviously going to be
plumbing fixtures so if we go
wc
it will give you the water closet 25
suite so let's say i like that one click
ok
drop it in fantastic let's go back into
our settings let's type in vanity basin
25 i like that one okay drop it in
it's really simple to start getting
objects in to the project if i click on
that project you'll see it's on the
wrong layer though it's on objects
landscaping i'd want that on mep
plumbing and i'd want that on mep
plumbing as well
what you'll notice is it's just
disappeared if that ever happens we go
into our settings command l control l
scroll down to that mep plumbing turn it
on click ok
and there it is if we come back into 3d
and pan around we can see our toilet and
our vanity basin a smack bang in the
middle of the room exactly how we drew
them in 2d now there isn't too much more
i should really talk about in a day one
video this is probably a day two or
three now that i'm getting into but i'll
just touch on it very briefly what
you'll see is our elevation and our
section lines
looking in our view map on the right
hand side again we can go down to sketch
elevations and e01 e01
e02 e02 so whichever way these arrows
point is the elevation we will be
looking at so as an example let's click
e01 it'll open up a new window
and it'll show us that elevation of what
we've created again in 3d so we don't
have to go back and draw it a million
times over
changing every single line changing
every corner and basically wasting so
much time with 2d software anyway that's
all for me today guys thank you so much
for watching i hope you enjoyed the
video i apologize if it was a little bit
less enthusiastic than usual i've just
come back from an incredibly long work
trip and it's 7 p.m in the middle of the
week i'm exhausted but i have to get
these videos out for you guys because i
promise them to you every single monday
so simply for that i hope that
encourages you to smash that subscribe
button down below and also the like
button the like button helps with the
youtube algorithm believe it or not i
know everybody says it but you guys have
been smashing it in recent times and
this channel has been growing
exponentially so i know for a fact that
that like button definitely contributes
to the success of this channel thank you
so much for being here and as always
i'll see you next monday